under pressure tonight the University of
Connecticut finally lets student spots
are a conservative speaker on campus
again this is after violent protests
erupted outside and inside the hall were
the Gateway pundits Lucien wint rich
spoke back in November well The Daily
wires ben shapiro just wrapped up a
speech hosted by the College Republicans
here's a sample something has to be done
about a system where a few crazed
leftists decide they don't want to hear
somebody speak and therefore people from
the outside who pay taxes to
universities like this one can't get in
it's a great thing the universities have
people like me and yes like the person
who's speaking opposite me on this
campus to give a variation of ideas oh
my gosh those words are so dangerous I
mean the university actually offered I
kid you not
counseling to students who might be
upset even at the mention or the thought
of Shapiro's appearance he looks like an
unsuspecting guy to me well let's ask
the man himself appearing on the angle
exclusively in a new segment we're
calling back to school it's kind of a
Ron D Rodney Dangerfield thing
did you traumatize snowflakes on campus
tonight van I mean you look so just
innocent and nice and they seemed very
upset about the prospect of your
arriving you were in the stores campus
correct yeah that's right I mean it's so
yeah they was very intimidating I mean
beneath this innocuous exterior lies the
heart of a monster and I just went in
and started tearing people apart I
jumped into the audience I know I ripped
at least one guy's throw it out but in
in actuality none of those things
happened of course and and this is
what's so funny I mean this is the last
campus where they've had to bring out
dozens of security members of the dozens
of cops that the staties were on call
apparently all because of what happened
when when Lucien came to speak and
that's not rare I mean when I was at
Berkeley they had to bring hundreds of
police officers when I was at
Northwestern they banned the the public
from from coming when I was at
University of Wisconsin the front of the
stage was taken over and when I was at
Cal State LA and your riot broke out so
it varies based on campus and tonight
thank God was was actually relatively
calm I think a lot of that had do with
the fact that the university really did
its job in getting a lot of security out
there part
we had to the fact it was cold these are
Fairweather protestors they're not gonna
show up when it's 30 degrees that's part
of it part of it too I think is that the
the number of people who are allowed in
was limited I mean if you were from an
outside group you weren't allowed to
come even though there were all these
security officers available now was it
packed out bad it was a full full
auditorium er yeah I mean they could
have given us bigger space there about
500 seats all of them were full yeah but
they did prevent people who wanted to
come in from the outside coming in I was
told by the College Republicans there
are another six to seven hundred people
who wanted to come in and who were
turned away because if you're just a
taxpaying member the public and you
wanted to come they wouldn't allow you
without like Donald Trump I had 700
people outside and they couldn't get it
I'm just using there were 10,000 people
outside they would know been there were
so actually we have a clip we have a
clip of a student who actually wanted to
get in tonight let's watch it basically
said that even if there's open seats and
also unclaimed wristbands they're still
not gonna let us into the actual event
did they tell you why nope they just
said they said they're not people to
talk to that there's nobody that will
will come in and talk to us and even if
there is somebody inside there that you
know could help us or could kind of sort
this out they're not gonna come out and
talk to us what do you make of that they
don't want to scho this on why because
her peer oh now I couldn't tell from
that clip or by the look of the guy
whether he was like a friend or a foe I
was guessing foe but then at the end I
said friend I couldn't really tell was
like this man I could but apparently
they were they're like poor people want
to come in like no you can't go at some
point like my two of my brothers went to
UConn so I know the stores canvassed it
was a long time ago but I know it quite
well
and it can't be that scary for them just
to hear a conservative speak it pot it
can't do it you know I don't think that
it is as I said in the speech if you
actually have to go seek mental health
counseling because you hear that I'm
coming to campus you probably need to
seek mental health counseling for a
number of other issues that you have but
again it's the security that I think is
the new way that censorship is taking
place so as I've said you know they're a
bunch of campuses now
where the administration says yeah we're
happy to have a conservative speak but
we're not going to allow people to to
come and actually hear this that's what
happened to Berkeley they had a 1,500
seat theater they ruled out the top half
of the theater and I prevented people
who came same day from actually
attending it's not restricted to me this
is happening to a bunch of conservative
speakers around the country all in the
name of safety but Anita Hill spoke at
UConn last week and it was completely
open to the public so all you need to
have is a few leftists who are hard
nasty and make threats and then
presumably the entire public is barred
from coming in the name of safety of
course so it's like Obamacare you have
access to care in theory but you don't
really have carry your there but you
can't really hear you I just have to
read then because this is I was like
crying laughing the diversity officer at
UConn Joelle Murchison in her letter
that just you know went out before your
speech that we understand even the
thought of an individual coming to
campus with the views that mr. Shapiro
expresses can be concerning and even
hurtful please utilize the many campus
resources available if you should want
to talk through your feelings about this
issue including my office the cultural
centers Dean of Students I actually want
to go pay her a visit and say I've had
it I've had a tough day today and I just
I really need some you know just a hug I
mean you just need a hug
well then I'm more useless it was fun
and and I will say this there's no more
useless title on campus than chief
diversity officer whose entire job is to
just pretend to care about a bunch of
people who are too weak need to actually
come in here it's a sending point of
view alright Ben Shapiro and great to
talk to you